quatre milliards et demi de dollars
valent bien un hymne national
après quatre ans de travaux dont six
mois de retard inauguration en grande
pompe du pont le plus large du canada
celui qui sera aussi le plus achalandé
au pays nous sommes des bâtisseurs ce
pan en est une démonstration sans
équivoque mesdames et messieurs en si
peu de temps
deux mille hommes et femmes ont fait
sortir de terre cet ouvrage qui est
maintenant un des symboles de notre
ville le ministre champagne avait une
bonne nouvelle pour les cyclistes
la piste multifonctionnelle du nouveau
pont sera ouverte
hiver comme été une première entre la
rive sud et montréal
ce pont est tout à l'image de ce vers
quoi on aspire à dire une province une
région métropolitaine une dynamique
audacieuse est définitivement bien
ancrée dans le 21e siècle le pont samuel
de champlain deviendra sans doute une
icône importante pour toute la région
métropolitaine de montréal
dites-vous que brassard est très fier
d'en tenir un bout au cours de la
cérémonie un aîné wac a béni le nouveau
pont un buste de samuel de champlain a
également été dévoilé il sera installé
sur la structure les travailleurs ont
aussi eu droit à deux ovations debout
non là on aux familles les amis on peut
avoir cette saison sa mère n'ont été
dangereux comme de nuit faire beaucoup
de sacrifices c'est à une joie de
participer à l' ouvrage est aujourd'hui
tout a été beau et quand on est arrivé à
la faire dieu merci le concepteur du
pont le célèbre architecte danois paul
ouvriers hans ont dit avoir vécu une de
ces belles expériences professionnelles
je suis impressionné et heureux que la
construction se soit fait si vite at il
dit il est comme je l'avais imaginé ces
voix du nouveau pont samuel de champlain
en direction de la rive-sud seront
officiellement ouvertes à compter de
lundi matin mais dès ce soir vendredi
l'ancien pont champlain sera
officiellement fermée à la circulation
rappelons qu'au cours des cinq dernières
années
ottawa a investi plus de 400 millions de
dollars pour qu'il tienne le coup
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et à compter de l'an
prochain un autre 400 millions de
alors ce sera nécessaire pour sa
déconstruction ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio canada sur le pont samuel
de champlain entre montréal et brossard